- I just watched the scariest movie on Netflix,
^Veronica with all my friends.
^We just had our socks scared off of us.
^We had a ton of fun, I love watching movies
with my friends.
Here's what went down.
(energetic electronic music)
Veronica, a Spanish horror movie
that is currently considered the most horrifying movie
on Netflix.
(Spanish rock music)
^- So Chris, you're the only one here
^who has seen the movie.
^What are we getting into?
- It's pretty scary.
It's somewhat based on a true story.
The police report I guess was like the first time.
- There was a police report?
- There was a police report.
- No.
- He actually like used paranormal
as like his reasoning for the case
so that makes it like kind of legit.
^- I'm scared of like the supernatural side,
^the side you can't see--
^- Same, because you--
- Because you
can't fight that!
- Exactly.
- You can't fight that!
- You can fight a serial killer,
you can fight like a crazy animal.
- That's what I'm saying!
- a werewolf.
- I don't (beep) with animals.
- The supernatural...
No, supernatural, no human can like deal with that.
^- I don't like the idea of being possessed.
^'cause it's like, you're your own worst enemy at that point.
That's one of my biggest fears, quite honestly.
- So, we're all wearing heart rate monitors right now.
Aren't they great?
We will be checking in during the movie
to see how scared we are based
on how our heart rate goes up and down.
And hopefully everyone will be there
no one's gonna die.
So we wanna play a drinking game.
- Yes!
- While we get through this.
I feel like anytime there's a jump scare that's a drink,
any other rules?
- Every five seconds that's a sip
- I mean...
(laughing)
(scary music)
(heart beating)
- I'm scared already.
You better do it, Sam.
- I'm just drinking, until demon shows up.
Guys, is something scary gonna happen now?
Everyone take a vote, I say yes.
- I wanna burst into tears, so I'm going to say yes.
- No.
(everyone gasps)
- Oh my gosh!
- [Sam] Oh shit.
- It's gonna break
- [Joyce] Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh
- This is it, this is it.
- [Sheridan] La la la la.
(scary music and screaming)
(gasps)
- Everyone drink, everyone drink.
I'm sweating right now.
- I have a question.
You see these apocalypse movies,
all this shit like that, horror movies.
Why do most people die?
They die 'cause they're like
oh my God, my husband something's wrong with him,
let me go check on him.
What you gotta do, is run away.
That's why I would survive like a zombie apocalypse.
Because the second someone's acting weird
I'd be like,
- Yeah, I'm out.
- There must be something supernatural at play, peace.
- When she opened her mouth, I would have sprinted,
sprinted away.
Like, and I would say,
ho, yo, she's in the basement.
She's doing some weird like witch stuff.
- I don't know, I'm pretty protective
and I think if my friend was doing that,
I'd probably try to shake it out of them or
I would need at least 20 minutes of pure panic
before I got a real good thing together.
So it would just be chaos.
- That smoking nun, is my idol.
And she's gonna be the new wallpaper on my phone.
- [Joyce] Same.
- So we're going to do a round of meme this
with the smoking nun.
We'll start with Chris.
I need you to give me your best caption
for the smoking nun.
- This could be like a new format,
like the Kermit with the tea,
^but it could be like that's nun of my business.
^Like nun-wise
- Oh, that'd be good.
- I like that.
- You like it?
^- I don't know, when the patriarchy tries to get you down.
(laughs)
- I love you, social justice.
- It would be a picture of Carrie Bradshaw smoking
from Sex in the City and it would be
^me at 29 and it would be this picture.
^(laughing)
^- When he doesn't text you back.
^- [Chris] Damn, straight up.
- It would be
^"Lucifer?
^I haven't heard that name in years."
(laughing)
- Well, I'm terrified.
- See, that's why you can't be messing
with the cult and ouija boards, that's for professionals.
You gotta know what you're doing before you enter anything.
(scary music)
- Actually, has anyone died yet?
- Not yet.
- Nope.
- That's not a good sign.
- Who is Diana?
- I just wanna let everyone know my heart rate is 112.
- I genuinely don't know how this ends.
(scary music)
(all scream)
- No, no, no, no, you crack open that...
(all gasp)
- Who would do that?
- No!
- [Kate] Are you (beep) kidding me?
(all screaming)
- That is not funny.
- That is wrong!
- Turn the lights on.
Who the (beep) is that?
^- [Chris] Holy (beep).
^- Ella!
- That's so (beep) up.
- That's so fucked up.
We missed the end because you had to be an (beep).
- Wow.
(heart beating)
^- 97 over 68, so 68.
^- You're way too chill right now.
^Mine is 97 over 102, which I feel like is not good.
^- [Sam] What?
^- Or? Maybe it is good?
- Hold on, is it?
^- That can't be right.
- Look at my finger, it's shaking.
- I've literally never been calmer,
it's 97 over 66.
(laughs)
^- Mine is 95 over 85, I feel like that's not good.
- Wow, mine's 94 over 111.
So I'm having a heart attack.
(scary music)
- Okay guys, let's play a little game
of Veronica, would you rather?
- I would rather not.
^- Would you rather participate in a seance using ouija board
^or spend a night in the room of the woman Veronica
^is based off of?
- Spend the night.
- I'd spend the night with her.
I'm not doing nothing with ouija board, all right?
^- Would you rather date someone who participates
^in ouija board seances, or someone--
^- No!
- Nah!
^- Wait, or someone who puts pineapples on their pizza?
- Pineapples on their pizza, that's delicious.
- I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
- Seances.
- I don't do pineapple.
- Well, obviously, if they put pineapple on their pizza
they don't have very good taste,
so the fact that they wanna date me
would be a slight against me.
- It doesn't mean you don't have good taste
it simply means that you think
pineapples on pizza taste good, it does.
- No, it means you have terrible taste
and you need to rethink your entire life.
- I hate pineapples.
- [Kate] Sheridan, this is very offensive.
- [Sheridan] Oh, Sheridan's being offensive?
(mysterious music)
- So guys we just watched Veronica
and how scary do you think that was?
- [Sheridan] Not that scary.
^- Honest to God, that was intense for me.
^- [Sheridan] Six.
- Honestly, psychologically, a 10.
Physically, like actually being scary,
^I would say like a solid six.
- Yeah, I think like a six or a--
^- Like it wasn't like oh my god!
^- It was like a six or a seven for me.
There were a lot of moments where I was like
sweating scared, but--
- Yeah.
- Yeah, like psychologically what I like about the film
is that the heights kept getting greater and greater.
And when it got to the climax of the film
you are attached to this character.
I was unattached to her until she had nobody.
(heart beating)
- Pitch me a bad sequel.
- Veronica moves to Riverdale.
(laughing)
- I heard she's dead.
- Enjoys Archie and the crew.
- [Sam] Right, okay.
- They're just in hell.
- Bad sequel or great sequel,
her younger siblings take out the ouija board
to try to talk to their dead sister.
- Oh, damn, that's a good sequel,
it's like Veronica 2, Veronicer.
- I think my sequel would be The Demonette
so all the demons that possessed her,
you know, fight for her love.
(laughing)
- Can everyone, we'll start with you, Chris
give me one big reason to see Veronica.
- Actually, I feel like it's a better movie
than most horror movies that they put out right now.
- So my favorite kind of movies are the ones
that you talk about a lot with your friends afterwards
because everyone takes a different thing away from it.
So I think this is a really good movie, 'cause it's like
we could probably talk about this for hours.
- I think there's a lot of metaphors
that we didn't even pick up on.
This movie was actually pretty good.
- I love Veronica's eyebrows.
- She's got great eyebrows.
- [Sam] Yeah, that's all I gotta say
- [Chris] That's what I expected.
- I feel like this movie for me,
why you should go see it
is because it's like life.
You know, you're freaked out, you're uncomfortable,
and then you realize everything is bull crap.
(laughing)
And then you except it, and you move on.
- Guys, thanks for watching Veronica with us.
I'm sweaty, scared, and tired
and I'm nervous about what we're gonna watch next
because that was pretty intense, right guys?
- I just wanna see like comedy.
- I'm emotionally drained.
(laughs)
- Me too.
- I don't have much left.
- She went through it.
- So did we, we went through it together.
(laughing)
- Right.
(lighthearted music)